[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوي
الكونجرس مستمر
انطلاقه مبادره السعوديه الخضراء في شرم
الشيخ 13 مشروعا للطاقه المتجدده قيد
التطوير
الاغتراب اللغوي فجوه بين الاسر السعوديه
وابنائها ودعوات لتعزيز العربيه لغه
وثقافه
الرابعه ايضا
المنتجات البحريه وجهه سياحيه متجدده
ومثاليه للسياح والاهالي في شرق السعودي
نبدا من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
تعيش صراعا كبيرا نحو اغلبيه الكونجرس بين
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي وفيما
تتواصل عمليات فرز الاصوات يحقق
الجمهوريون التقدما في مجلس النواب ويرد
الديمقراطيون بتحقيق مكاسب اخرى لفوز
للحزب الديمقراطي بمنصيب الحاكم على
الساحل الغربي لامريكا كالمعتاد تعد
الانتخابات النصفيه موعد محوريه للسياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه وتتولى العديد من
التساؤلات عن كيفيه التعاطي واشنطن مع
سياستها الخارجيه بعد اقتراع الكونجرس يرى
خبراء ان الانقسام في امريكا وارد جدا حول
سياسه الخارجيه في حال فاز الجمهوريون
ويذهب اخرون الى التعاون بين الحزبين
واستمرار سيطره البيت الابيض على سياسه
الخارجيه
[موسيقى]
وتتجهين الان الى ولايه الى ولايتين بعد
وارزقنا التي يتنافس الجمهوريون
والديمقراطيون فيهما على مقاعد مجلس
الشيوخ في ما يتواصل حتى الان فرز الاسود
واعلن مسؤول واريز اكثر من 400 الف صوت
يتواصلوا حتى الاسبوع المقبل خاصه في
مركوبه
100 صوت يتم الانتهاء من عندهم في الاسبوع
المقبل حسب قانون الولايه هناك فرصه حتى
يوم الاربعاء لمراجعه اي توقي
وتلك نسبه صغيره من اجمالي عدد الناخبين
الذين يصوتون في هذه الانتخابات
موجود يا جدع
[موسيقى]
ان
اوك انسان
[موسيقى]
اه في اخر تحديث للنتائج بحسب شبكه سي ان
ان الامريكيه حصل الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب حتى الان على 200 2011 مقعدا فيما
حصل الديمقراطيون على 188 اما بشان
المنافسه في مجلس الشيوخ والتي لم تحسم
نهائيا بعد فقد حصد الجمهوريون 49 مقعدا
بما حصل الديمقراطيون على 48 مقعدا حتى
الان
[موسيقى]
من واشنطن الدكتور وليد فارس الخبير في
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه دكتور وليد
اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه دكتور
يعني حتى الان لم تحسن
النتائج بشكل نهائي ولا يمكن معرفه
الحقائق في ما يتعلق بمشهد بشكل لكن
في ضوء هذه النتائج الاخيره في ضوء
النتائج ايضا متوقعه كيف يمكن استشراف
مستقبل السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه في شكل
الكونجرسها
صحيح حتى الان لا يمكن ان يكون هنالك موقف
في الرسمي او تحرير رسمي لما يمكن ان تكون
هذه السياسه بعد الانتخابات ولكن على
الاقل هنالك معادلتان لا ثالث لهما حسب
الارقام التي نراها اولا خيار الاول ان
يسيطر الجمهوريون على مجلس النواب فقط
ويستمر الديمقراطيون بالسيطر على المجلس
الشيوخ هذه واحد
ان يتمكن السبب ما الجمهوريون من استكمال
السيطره ايضا على مجلس الشيوخ هذا ما سوف
نعرفه من الان الى سته ديسمبر اذا تم احدى
هاتين السيناريوهات عندها سوف يكون هنالك
تاثير على السياسه الخارجيه بالطبع النقطه
الاولى السياسه الخارجيه يديرها البيت
الابيض تديرها الاداره دي موضوع دي موضوع
اختيار السفراء بموضوع
المعاهدات الى هناك ولكن الكونجرس له دور
كبير قد يؤثر خاصه اذا كان الهيئتان تحت
الحزب المعارض وحتى كانت هذه المعارضه
تملك فقد اكثريه في مجلس النواب وهما
المال يعني المساعدات الخارجيه الميزانيه
كل ذلك تحت قبه البرلمان المجلس النيابي
الامريكي وهو سوف يكون حتما بيد
الجمهوريين بالنسبه لمجلس الشيوخ وعندهم
قدره قبول المرشحين للمناصب للسفراء
للمدراء من قبل الاداره وعندهم ايضا قدره
توقيع المعاهدات اذن السيناريوهان سوف
يفرزان في الاسابيع المقبله يعني لو لو لو
كانت لو ولد الديمقراطيين الاغلبيه في
الكونجرس قد لا يتغير المشهد كثيره يعني
فيما يتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه ولذلك دائما
نناقش الاحتمال الثاني اللي هي سيطره
الجمهوريين على بالاغلبيه على على مجلس
الشيوخ في هذه الحاله هناك عده ملفات
ونبدا بملف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيا
حتى الان ايضا هناك غموض في الموقف
تصريحات متناقضه ومتضاربه يعني رئيس
الحزب الجمهوري في يتحدث على انه لن يعطى
هذا الملف شيكا على بيع بياض لاوكرانيا
لكن في المقابل الرئيس الامريكي اكد على
ان هناك صفقه او تفاهم تم خلال الايام
الماضيه مع الحزب الجمهوري ما
السيناريوهات المتوقع في التعاطي مع هذا
الملف
السيناريو الاكثر توقعاتا مبني على واقعان
الاول انه الحسبه الديمقراطي وهذه الاداره
يريدون الاستمرار بدعم اوكرانيا ديفايعيا
لا يريدون لاكرانيا ان تطلق الصواريخ على
الاراضي الروسيه والتصعيد خوفا من
الاشتباك لان هذا الموقف الاداره ومن معه
في الكونجرس الجمهوريون عدد منهم يريد
الاستمرار في الدعم ولكن هنالك عدد متزايد
يقول للراي العام لماذا نحن نصرف كل هذه
الميزانيات مليارات ومليارات من الدولارات
اذا النتيجه سوف تكون الموقف سيكون موحدا
بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين على ضروره
تلك الحرب مع الالتزام والتعاود بحمايه
اوكرانيا همم
العسكري هل سيستمر على نفس الوتيره ام
سيخف واذا كان سيخفف لن يكون ذلك يعني له
اثر على العلاقات الامريكيه الاوروبيه
بمعنى اخر السيد الدقيد في هذه العلاقه
التي ستجد نفسها في
منتصف الطريق بعد ان دعمتها او قدمتها
امريكا المواجهه مع روسيا كل شيء معقد
يعني ما يجري ايضا تحت الطاوله يؤثر بما
معناها هنالك كلام بين الامريكيين والروس
الان حول عدم التصعيد النووي حول محاوله
ايجاد وقف اطلاق نار وهذا الامر يدعمه
الاوروبيون تحت الطاوله ولكن بخطاباتهم
يقولون نحن سوف يواجه الروس الى هنا لكن
موقف الغربي لا يريد حرب مع الروسي ولكن
لا يريد لروسيا ان تشتاق اوكراني وبالتالي
هو الهدف الغربي بشكل مستقبل السياسه
الامريكيه مع الشرق الاوسط وقضايا لدينا
الملف النووي الايراني لدينا ما يتعلق بين
نتنياهو وعودته الى المشهد ايضا ما يتعلق
بالتفاقات الابراهيميه في هذه النقطتين ما
الذي سيتغير
اولا ان سيكون هناك تغيير كبير حيال
المفاوضات تجاه الملف النووي الايراني وهي
لايران فالاكثريه الاتيه الجمهوريه وهي
محافظه ومرتبطه يعني اكثريه من المسيحيين
المحافظين ومرتبطه ايضا بدعمها لاسرائيل
وطبعا لا ننسى انه الرئيس ترامب هو الذي
انجز الموقف الامريكي من قمه الرياض وقال
للعرب الشرق الاوسطين يجب مقاومه يعني
الدفاع عن المنطقه الجيران هذه الاكثريه
سوف تنجز موقف حاسم وقوي اتجاه ايران لن
تقبل بتمرير او توقيع اي اتفاق مع ايران
اذا اذا مجلس الشيوخ بحداته حتى كان ولو
بصوت واحد مع الديمقراطيين ايضا لن لن
ينجز هذا سوف يؤدي الى الاداره ان تتخذ
قرارا كبيرا وهو صعب ان توقع على هذا
الاتفاق في ظل هذه المظاهرات والرفط
الداخلي الامريكي همم بقرار تنفيذي هذا
صعب جدا يعني وهو مشكله الى امام الرئيس
امريكيه ايرانيه
ترى لا تريد هذه المواجهه طالما هي او
اللوبي الايراني الموجود بقربها يضغط يعني
اقامه علاقات طبيعيه مع ايران الا اذا
اخطات ايران وقامت بعمل غير طبيعي في
المنطقه عندها لكل حادث العلاقات مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الكثير من
المراقبين بانها لم تكن في احسن احوالها
مع اداره بيض النوم مع الكونجرس في الفتره
الماضيه هل سيتغير شيء في هذه العلاقه اذا
مسيطر الجمهوريون على المشهد في مجلس
الشعب
تتغير بعض الامور بتقديري اولا همم رئيس
بلديه كان يضغط على المملكه همم بحكم وجود
هذا اللغز الايراني من ناحيه وبحكم ايضا
وجود كتله في حزبه هي تنتقد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه منذ زمن ولكن الان مع
تغيير الاكثريه على الاطفال في مجلس
النواب وتحسين وضع الجمهوريين في مجلس
الشيوخ العلاقه الضغط من الكونجرس على
الاداره سوف يتكفف
لتعاطي مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كحاليف لماذا لانه من هو اقوى اقوى شخصيه
من هي اقوى شخصيه تؤثر على هذا الكون سوف
تكون دونالد ترامب واخرى وهو منجز
العلاقات التي ادت الى الدعم الامريكي
للتحالف العربي وربما بشكل غير مباشر حتى
ولو لم تكن المملكه جزءا من معاهده
ابراهيم هذا ادى قبول المملكه بهذا
الاستراتيجيه الجديده ادى الى اتفاقيه
ابراهيم وبالتالي هذا سوف يعني ان الضغط
على المملكه العربيه السعوديه سوف يتم باي
شكل الدكتور خلينا نحاول نحدد نكون محددين
اكثر العنوان العريض واعاده تقييم العلاقه
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه كما قال مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كما قال البيت
الابيض فبالتالي ما الذي سيتغير تحت هذا
العنوان او هذا التوجه فيما يتعلق بالدعم
همم العسكري في ما يتعلق ايضا يعني
بالكثير من القضايا التي همم
انت عاطي مع روسيا ربما كانوا من القضايا
المهمه يعني في في هذا الموضوع القضايا
النفطيه كيف سيتغير الموقف اوبك او نوبيك
وغيرها يعني اولا سيدي هذا الكلام يعني
باللغه الدبلوماسيه ما نعنيه باللغه
الاعلاميه انها سيكون هنالك ضغط على
المملكه عندما يقولون سوف نراجع يعني ما
هو الان قائم هو علاقه خاصه جدا سوف ربما
نحولها الى علاقه عاديه وربما اكثر من ذلك
بسبب الامر المعروف في الاعلام انه
المملكه
وحلفاءها في الاوبك وفي العالم العربي
قرروا ان لا يقبلوا بالطرح اداره فيما
يتعلق بانتاج هذا امر معروف جدا فبالتالي
جناحه اليسارعه ضغط اللوبي الايراني ادى
الى تغيير موقف بين ولكن هذا كان قبل
الانتخابات هذا الكونغرس الجديد لن يقبل
بان يكون هنالك اي معاهدات او تغيير في
نوعيه العلاقات الممتازه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
لكن بالطبع السياسه الخارجيه هنا هي بين
يدي الرئيس ولكن الرئيس يعرف تماما اذا
قام بهذا الضغط فالكونجرس لن يواكبه ولن
يدعمه بملفات اخرى اذن المفاوضات سوف تكون
في الاشهر الثلاثه الاولى من العام المقبل
حول هذا بشكل
الى التهدئه تجاه الملفات السياسيه
الخارجيه مع يعني ما قيل عن احتمالات يعني
حرب نوويه العلاقات مع الصين وربما تايوان
كذلك من المعطيات والملفات المهمه التي
يمكن ان تتعاطى مع الاداره الامريكيه بشكل
عام كيف تنظر الى الامر تهدئات تشدد همم
كلمه تهد ها هي الاكثر مناسبه لانه اذا
نظرنا الى الاكثريه الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب فهي لا تريد لا حروب خارجيه ولا
صدامات خارجيه وهي لا تريد ايضا التخلي عن
حلفاء التقليديين كانوا في الشرق الاوسط
او بما كان الاخر من ناحيه واداره ايضا
اذا نظرنا اليها هي تخاف وتخلص من تصعيده
غير قادره ان تلبيه لذلك اذا حسبنا
العاملان همم نقول ان السنه المقبله سوف
تكون سنه تهدئه بالنسبه للسياسه الامريكيه
الخارجيه ولكن بالتفاهم مع الاخصام يعني
المسيحيه ايضا بحاجه لهذا الموقف الامريكي
ولا تعرف كيف تصل
اليها بواسطه هذه الانتخابات
الدكتور فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكي
شكرا
[موسيقى]
في شرم الشيخ وبالتزامني مع مؤتمر المناخ
انطلقت النسخه الثانيه من مبادره السعوديه
الخضراء وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان اكد ان الرياض احدثت
تحولا هاما نحو الطاقه الخضراء واشار وزير
الطاقه السعوديه الى ارساء 13 مشروعا
للطاقه المتجدده خلال العام الحالي
باستثمارات تبلغ 34 مليون ريال من جهتي
كشف وزير البيئه والمياه والزراعه
السعوديه عبد الرحمن الفضلي ان استراتيجيه
المملكه للبيئه تتضمن خمسه او 65 مبادره
على مدارس سنوات الثمان القادمه
اسعد فرندي
عزف بفيديو الشوينج مشتركه
[موسيقى]
الميجا وات
واذا المدينه
شرم الشيخ العربي احمد عثمان اهلا احمد
احمد ايضا لمداره كلها اليوم لا شرم الشيخ
ربما لكلمه منتظره للرئيس الامريكي
لكن بشكل عام ابرز ما تم رصده هذا اليوم
في قمه شرم الشيخ
الى
الانظار مواجهه الى كلمه الرئيس المفترض
انه وصل مصر منذ حوالي 10 دقائق
اربع يعني
اطار خادمه الولايات المتحده في مؤتمر كاب
27 في شرم الشيخ وهي الكلمه التي كان من
المفترض ان تكون يوم الاثنين الماضي اثناء
منه اجلت بطبيعه الحال
للرئيس بالانتخابات المصريه من المتوقع
بان هذه الكلمه في ستاتي في سباق الكلمات
التي جاءت الدول
الغربيه او الدول السوريه او الدول الشمال
والذي يراها هذا العام بانها كثير من
الخبراء يؤكدونا تمثل
طيب انا مضطر
ل مقاطع شكرا جزيلا لك منى احمد عثمان
نعتذر لهذه المشكله الفنيه من
مصدر طيب
مستندات كبيره لمبادره السعوديه الخضراء
لكن هل هي واقعيه ماذا ايضا عن واقع
المبادره حتى الان زميل سالم الرجح ياخذنا
عبر تقنيه الواقع المعزز
طموحات كبيرات تسعى اليها المملكه من خلال
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء التي تستهدف
وتفجير المدن والاوديه والطرق السريعه
اولا ستزرع السعوديه نحو مئه مليون شجره
مانجروف في السواحل هنا كما نعرف كل
المقومات متوفره بين المياه والاجواء
الساحليه ولكن ماذا عن هذه الصحراء كيف
ستتم زراعه هذه الصحاري التي تمتد حتى
الافق السعوديه الخضراء ستعمل على زراعه
الاشجار في اجزاء كبيره من هذه الصحراء
لكنها الامر بهذه البساطه ماذا عن الماء
في السعوديه بلدهم صحراويه تؤرقه وفره
الماء
التغلب على هذا التحدي ياتي من خلال عده
خطوات اولها اختيار الاشجار المحليه التي
تتحمل حراره الاجواء مثل السدر والطلح
وغيرها بالاضافه الى اختياري مواطن المياه
وزراعه الاش فيها تتحدث تحديدا عن
الاستفاده من الامطار الموسميه من خلال
الزراعه في مجال الاوديه بالاضافه الى
السدود المنتشره في جميع المدن السعوديه
المناطق السعوديه ترتبط ببعضها من خلال
شبكه طرق ضخمه وبمسافات طويله تشجير هذه
الطرق سيكون احد
مستهدفاتره من خلال زراعه اكثر من 30
مليون شجره بالتعاون بين وزاره البيئه
والزراعه والمياه ووزاره النقل ما رايكم
ان نذهب لداخل المدن التشجير داخل المدن
هو احد اهم نطاقات المبادره اولا ستعمل
امانات المناطق على التجهيز البنيه
التحتيه مثل ما ترون من خلال الاحواض
المناسبه والارصفه وتوصيل انابيب المياه
قبل ان تبدا عمليه الزراعه الاشجار ستكون
جزء الرئيسيا من مرافق الاحياء في الرياض
مثلا ستزرع الاشجار تسعه الاف في مسجد
وسته الاف مدرسه
و400 مركز صحي بالاضافه الى العديد من
المرافق العامه هذه الاهداف الكبيره تحتاج
الى كميات ضخمه من المياه من اين سيتم
توفيرها
يوجد في السعوديه 125 محطه لمعالجه المياه
تنتج يوميا خمسه ملايين و260 الف متر مكعب
ولديها قدره استعابيه لانتاج اكثر من سته
ملايين متر مكعب ولكن
22% فقط يعني نسبه المياه التي يعادوا
استخدامها بينما نحن 80% من هذه الكميات
يتم هدرها في بطون الاوديه دون الاستفاده
منها لذلك ستكون هذه المحطات المصدر الاهم
لري الاشجار في السعوديه
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
السياحه في البحرين تتعا فا زياده عدد
السياح بالنسبه 20% في الربع الثالث من
عام 20022 مقارنه ب2019
اكثر من 400 الف صوت
انطلاق مبادره السعوديه الخضراء في شرم
الشيخ 13 مشروعا للطاقه المتجدده قيد
التطوير
الاغتراب اللغوي فجاه بين الاسر السعوديه
وابنائها ودعوات لتعزيز العربيه لغه
وثقافه
المنتجعات البحريه وجهه سياحيه متجدده
ومثاليه للسياخ والاهالي في شرق السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد تواجه العديد من
العائلات السعوديه ازمه في التواصل باللغه
العربيه مع ابنائها حيث نشا الاف من
الاطفال السعوديين في بلدان الابتعاد ما
تسبب بقصور في فهم اللغه العربيه
واستخدامها للتواصل الى جانب عائلات اخرى
اتجهت لتعليم ابنائها في المدارس العالميه
التي تعتمد التدريس باللغه الانجليزيه
الامر الذي فاقم ازمه اللغه الام لدى
اعداد كبيره من الاطفال
تعليم الاطفال عمليه بالغه التعقيد
والحساسيه
التطور الكبير والتداخل المعرفي خلق حاجزا
كبيرا تجاه اللغه العربيه
يواجهه جيل من الطلاب في السعوديه سواء
كان ذلك بسبب مرافقتهم لعائلاتهم للخارج
بغرض الدراسه او حتى تسجيلهم بالمدارس
العالميه داخل السعوديه بعض هذه العائلات
تنبهت لحجم المشكله وبعضها لم ينتبه حتى
الان بعد ما عادوا المملكه
اللي قاعد خمس سنين اربع سنين سبع سنين
فالطفوله ابنائه كلها كانت
في الخارج يعني فكانت اللغه العربيه ليست
يعني
ليست حديث اليوم بالبيت يعني احس بالذنب
انه ابي ولدي يوصل هالمرحله ابغاه لما
يسمع بيت شعر او لما يسمع باب اولى مثلا
ايه قرانيه او حديث باللغه العربيه فيه
معاني ابغاويه يحس فيه زي ما انا حس فيه
يعني ما الذي استطيع ان نفعله كي كي نجد
حلولا لي مساله الاغتراب اللغوي الان يجب
ان نقول منذ البدايه اللغه الانجليزيه
مطلب اتقان لغه اجنبيه عالميه هو اليوم كي
نكون واقعيين هو اليوم ضروري
ولازم وممكن جدا ليست في هذه القضيه
الكبيره وانما اللغه الام اتقان اللغه
الام اكتسابا وتعلما هو طبعا الاساس يرى
مختصون ان الحمل يقع على عاتق الجهات
التعليميه حيث ان مناهج اللغه العربيه
تفتقر لاساليب الجذب اللازمه بعكس
الانجليزيه عبد الرحمن الحضيف احد الاباء
الذين يعانون من هذه المشكله مع ابنائهم
حيث قرر اخيرا تاسيسا مبادره لتعليم
العربيه لتجاوز هذه المعطله احنا نشاطنا
مراكز اعمال
وهذا هيا مكان جاهز انه نطلق مبادره للغه
العربيه
فكان الفكره انه تواصلنا مع احد
الجهات والشركات المختصه في هذا المجال
وطلعنا باتفاقيه ان شاء الله تظهر للنور
قريبا كمبادره لاستخدام احد المراكز هذه
الاطلاق مبادره للغه العربيه
في ان اللغه جزء من الهويه هكذا وصف احد
الاباء دوافعه لاعاده تعليم ابنائه اللغه
العربيه
بالرغم من المتاعب التي يواجهها اولياء
الامور بسبب تنشئه ابنائهم بعيدا عن اللغه
الام الا ان المحاولات قائمه داخل العديد
من الاسري لتدارك هذا الموقف العصير
من الرياض عبد الواحد الحميد العربيه
من استديوهات ايضا في الرياضيات
في اللغويات التطبيقيه في جامعه الملك
سعود حياك الله اهلا وسهلا حياك دكتور
خلني ابدا معك من مشهد لا يختلف كثيرا عن
ما قاله الزملاء طبعا في التقرير السابق
مجموعه من طلاب احدى المدارس العالميه
زارتنا في قناه العربيه معدل اعمارهم من
سبع الى عشر سنوات كان عندنا مشكله في
التواصل معهم بشكل حقيقي
يتحدثون باللغه الانجليزيه ولما جينا نجرب
معهم يعني قراءه نصوص على الواتس كيو كانت
همم يعني عندهم مشكله في قراءتها وطلبوا
تغيير الى اللغه الانجليزيه
هذا نتكلم عن حوالي 20 طالبه يمثلون واحده
من 1900 تقريبا او 2000 مدرسه عالميه
واجنبيه في الرياض تحت بس و 50,000 تقريبا
طالب وطالبه موجودين في هذه المدرسه هذا
جيل جديد هل نعاني من مشكله
الحديث عن اهميه اللغه الام في التعليم
واثرها ايضا في ازدهار الثقافه والحضاره
هو امر محسوم تقريبا في الابحاث العلميه
حتى المنظمات الدوليه التي من صالحها ان
تروج اللغه الانجليزيه بان تكون لغه مهمه
مثل ما تسمى اللينجو فرانكا مثل ما ذكرت
الزميله الباحثه حول ذلك واهميه ضروره
اللغه الانجليزيه الا انهم يدافعون عن
اللغه الام بشكل كبير وهذا يعطي طيفا
وتنوعا كبيرا في العالم ويكون لكل مكان
لونه وثقافته الخاص همم الزملاء او ال-
ال- الطلاب الذين زاروا العربيه وهذا
المشهد الذي وصفته للاسف هو مؤسف جدا هم
لم ااه
يعانوا فقط من التحدث باللغه العربيه هم
هنا عذروا حتى عن الموهبه العربيه هم هنا
عزل حتى عن التراث العربي وحتى على الارث
العربي وحتى عن الشعور والمشاعر اليوم انت
لو تقول لهم سم او لبيه لن تكون ابدا
وقعها مثل كلمه يس او اي كلمه مقابله لها
فبالتالي حتى اذكر مؤسسه لها مبادره جميله
سمتها سمات الشخصيه السعوديه من ضمن سمات
الشخصيه السعوديه وجدت ان اللغه العربيه
هي احد اهم ركائز هذه السمات لان صفات
الشعوب مجتنزه في لغاتهم فكلمه كرم وشهامه
لا يقابلها اي الترجمه في العالم لانها
تعبر عنكم مثل ما يقول بالجني ان اللغه
اصوات يعبر بها كل قوم عن اغراضه فاولئ
الطلبه لم يعبر عن اغراضهم بلغتهم وانما
بلغه غيرهم وهنا تكون المشكله هذه المشكله
للاسف بدات تتفاقم احد الزملاء تحت الهواء
قبل قليل ونحن نحضر لهذه يسالني يقول هل
هي بندر ظاهره اللي حصل في العربيه ذكرت
لا بانه كلمه ظاهره تحتاج دولي الى نعم
الا لانه الحضارات والدول المتقدمه في
العالم تهتم لذلك وتصنع مؤشرات وقد يكون
اشهرها مؤشر كجان في مؤشر قوه اللغات في
العالم واثرها وكان فيها نطاقات كبيره جدا
ومؤسسه من المسؤول اذا كانت هناك الكلام
من المسؤول عنها مؤسسات التعليم واحد
المؤسسات التنشئه الاجتماعيه في البلد ولا
الاسر جميل هذا سؤال رائع جدا وياتي كثيرا
اعتقد انه المسؤول في الطراز الاول هو
مؤسسات التعليم والمؤسسات الكبيره الافراد
لا يستطيعون ان يقاومون تيارا كبيرا هو
يجرف الكثير من
الثقافات سواء على مستوى سهل التواصل
الاجتماعي او على مستوى الشبكه المفتوحه
او على مستوى الافلام وذكرتهم ايضا في
التقرير ان كل ما يقدم باللغه الانجليزيه
واكثر تشويقا الفيلم الانجليزي اكثر
تشويقا الروايه الانجليزيه اكثر تشويقا
الكتاب التعليمي للغه الانجليزيه كثرت
شويقا فهذا التيار الكبير لا يصده الا
تيار نوعا ما مشابهه على الاقل على
المستوى المحلي بان يقدم اللغه العربيه
بتراز الرفيع الا يقدمها بتصورات الشعبيه
القديمه لا بتقعر ولا بمبالغه في همم
التصح وانما لها جاءتنا الطبيعيه التي
نتحدث بها ونزهه بها ونفخر وايضا اللغه
العربيه بشكل عام المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بتعيير هذا الامر اهتماما كبيرا
على مستوى التشريعات الماده الاولى من
النظام الاساسي للحكم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه دوله عربيه اسلاميه ذات سياده
تامه دستورها كتاب الله وسنه رسوله ولغتها
اللغه العربيه وعاصمتها الرياض 49 قرار
مجلس الوزراء وايضا قرارات ساميه كانت في
دعم اللغه العربيه الا انها اليوم الا
نراها للاسف على الميدان مسميات كثيره
تكون باللغه الانجليزيه سواء بمبادارات
كثيره احنا ذكرنا انه المشكله يمكن ان
طلاب الابتعاث اكبر من ناحيته كثير كان له
طلاب ايضا وهم في امريكا وفي اوروبا وفي
الدول اللي كانوا يعني الحديث داخل البيوت
هو باللغه العربيه ما وجهه اي مشكله لما
لما وصلوا الى او رجعوا الى المملكه على
العكس نشوف في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بعض اولياء الاموره انه ابناءهم يتكلموا
معهم في البيت باللغه الانجليزيه يعني
ويمكن هذه المشكله نجعلها
الدوري الاسره هنا مفقود مو عيب انه انه
انه يتعلم اللغه الاجنبيه بصفه لغه عالميه
وهي اللغه رقم واحد لكن اعتقد انه مسؤوليه
اكبر كذلك يجب ان تكون على الاسر بلا شك
همم الاسره لها دور كبير جدا ان اتكلم عن
المشهد العام الماء يعني المشهد اللغوي
العام هو مسؤوليه كبيره تقوم بها المؤسسات
اما على مستوى الاسره الصغيره فحتى يعني
كبار الباحثين كلهم كراش المسؤولين عن
اكتساب اللغه الثانيه يقول ان حديث الام
لابنها باللغه غير لغتها الاصليه هو عقوق
من الام الى ال- ال- الابن وتقصر في
واجباته وحقوقه ولهذا السبب تقول اليونسكو
انه عام 2016 قالت ان همم يعني اطلقت
مبادره كبيره سمتها التدريس الجيد
والتعليم باللغه الام لابد ان يكون
التعليم باللغه الالم حتى تكبر هذه
الانتماء لهذه الثقافه تستطيع الاسره ان
توازن بين اللغه الانجليزيه واللغه
العربيه اكبر معضلا وجهها تدور في كثير من
الالسن
الطفل يستطيع ان يكتسب اكثر من لغه ثم
نكتشف في الاخير انهم قدموا اللغه
الانجليزيه من ناطق عربي امه واب يتكلمون
العربيه يقدمون لغه انجليزيه لابن لا
يتلقى الا هذه الانجليزيه فضيع مشيته
ومشيت الحمامه وهذا يسمى اصلا علميا
بالسيلينج ولزم الذي هو لا هو اخذ
الانجليزيه من اهلها وياخذها من امه وابوه
وله هو حافظ على العربيه التي تعبر عن
هويته قد يقول انه هذا الامر طبيعي احنا
اليوم ضمن عالم ااه متطور ومختلف ومتغير
اسمح لي انا بكتفي بهذا القدر دكتور بندر
لانه مضطرين للذهاب الى شرم الشيخ الان
لمتابعه
التطورات من هناك الان يصل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن الى مطار شرم الشيخ
نشاهده الان ينزل من سلم الطائره
لارض المطار
ونتابع الانستقبال في ارض المطار في شرم
الشيخ للمشاركه من قبل الرئيس الامريكي في
مؤتمر همم رقم 27
الكثير من القضايا
سينقشر الرئيس الامريكي وايضا نحن نترقب
كلمه الرئيس الامريكي التي تاتي عليها
مشاهدي القمه اعود اليك دكتور بندر
الفكره انه احنا
ضمن العالم يعني والعالم يتغير انا اريد
يعني ان اقارن بين المشهد ايضا تابعته في
اليابان في 2003
كان المشهد ان هناك اعتداد كبير من قبل
مواطن الياباني ويرفض حتى ربما الحديث معك
بلغه اخرى حتى لو كانت اللغه الانجليزيه
عندما تسال عن امر ما او عن عنوان ما يعني
هذا المشهد تغير كثير
قبل الحمل تقريبا اصبحت اللغه الانجليزيه
تقريبا تقارب اللغه اليابانيه احنا جزء من
هذا العالم يعني فبالتالي ليس هناك مشكله
في ما يحدث من ناحيه التطور التغير التحضر
وغيرهما جميل اليابان الذي هي مثل المشهور
اذا ابتعد لديهم همم طالب الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او اي دوله ناطقه اصليه
باللغه الانجليزيه يعطونه مقص فيقول له
الوالد اذا ابوه او امه اذا سافرت الى تلك
الدوله وتحدثت اليوميه ساقص لسانك يقصد
انه ولدك ان تمارس اللغه ولكن ان عدت الى
اليابان وتحدثت معي بالانجليزيه ايضا سوف
مره اخرى هنا ياتي الاعتزاز والتوازن
الرائع جدا بين اللغه هي لغه عالميه لا
نكرهها سواء في البحث العلمي والمعرفه
والتطور وبين اللغه الام التي همم يعني
تحافظ على ارتك وتاريخك واعت ذلك همم هل
هذا الامر يحصل على مستوى العالم وانه امر
طبيعي نعم لكن هل جهود من الان همم تعتبر
كافيه للموازنه بين اللغتين اعتقد ان
نحتاج الى جهود اكبر وتوعيه اكبر جهود
يعني على والدبلوماسي على مستوى دعم
المملكه للغه العربيه في الكثير من
الفعاليات والمنظمات الدوليه ليونسكو
وغيرها من الامور ما يكفي هذا الامر انا
اعتقد انه الجهد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
خارجيا تعتبر يعني
ترفع الراس ومشرفه لجميع الدول العربيه
خصوصا في القرار المشهور 3190 لليونسكو في
اقرار اللغه العربيه عام 1973 بان تكون
لغه رسميه وسادسه على همم في في هذه
المنظمه المتحده معاهد كثيره استطيع ان
اتحدث ثلاث ساعات عن جهود المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في دعم اللغه العربيه باموال
كبيره لا ترجوا منها الا تعزيز الهويه
لهذه اللغه وما تحمله من الارث لكن اليوم
اذا كنت تدور في في كثير من المحلات تجد
كثير من همم يعني النشاطات التجاريه تكون
محليه ونشات محليه ولكنها باللغه
الانجليزيه تجد كثير من المسؤولين او داخل
الاجتماعات او ايضا في البريد الالكتروني
في الاجتماع باللغه الانجليزيه لا يوجد
احد يتكلم عربي عفوا انجليزي الجميع يتكلم
عربي باستطاعتهم ان يواصل الحديث باللغه
العربيه الا ان اللغه الانجليزيه اخذت
مكانه وحموله بانها لغه تحضر ولغه تقدم
وهذا في المؤشرات اللغويه بالمناسبه يسمى
الموقف اللغوي الاجتماعي ما موقفنا اللغوي
من اللغه العربيه اليوم هل نراها يعني حتى
انا دائما اقول مثال طريف تسمع اللغه
العربيه اليوم للاسف في جنوب الرياض ولكن
لا تسمعها في شمال الرياض تسمعها في محل
الفول والقلابه لكن لا تسمعها في المطعم
همم الفاخر جدا هذه
الازدواجيه تعطي سرديه همم سيئه عن اللغه
العربيه وكانها لغه لا ترقى لان تكون في
الاماكن همم الرفيعه الشانكي شكرا
اللغويات
في لقاء مع العربيه على هامشي سوق السفر
العالميه كده فاطمه السير في وزيره
السياحه البحرينيه
جدا في مملكه البحرين مشيره الى زياده عدد
السياح بالنسبه 20% في الربع الثالث من
هذا العام مقارنه بالفتره المماثله من عام
البحرين في الربع الثالث من هذه السنه
بالربع الثالث ايه في 2019 انما ان هي في
نسبه زياده ما تقارب العشرين بالمئه
وعندما نرى ان كيف المؤشرات السياحيه ااه
اجماليه همم في نهايه عام 2019 مقارنه
بالربع الثالث او نهايه الربع الثالث في
2000 همم 2002 22 نرى ان نسبه التعافي
السياحي وصلت الى ما يقارب ال 85% فهذه
المؤشرات مؤشرات طيبه وتعكس ماما جاء همم
تطور مملكه البحرين في المجال السياحي
رابعه ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل
المنتجعات البحريه وجهه سياحيه متجدده
ومثاليه للسياخ والاهالي شرقي السعودي
اهلا بكم من جديد شهد مؤتمر ومعرض كارتنر
لتنقيه المعلومات او تقنيه المعلومات
المقام في مدينه برشلونه الاسبانيه
المشاركه سعوديه واسعه من خلال جناح يضم
تسع جهات حكوميه تهدف بدورها الى نقل
تجربه السعوديه الرائده في التحول الرقمي
والاستفاده من افضل الممارسات العالميه في
مجال الحكم الرقميه تضمنت اهم الجهات
السعوديه المشاركه كلا من هيئه الحكومه
الرقميه وزاره الداخليه والصحه والعدل
وغيرها من الجهاد
افادت الهيئه العامه للاعلام المرئي
والمسموع في السعوديه بان المجموعه ما
حجبته من العاب الالكترونيه منذ عام 2016
لا يتجاوزوا 60 لعبه وذلك لاسباب جوهريه
مؤكده انها فسحت خلال الفتره ذاتها لاكثر
من ثلاثه الاف لعبه العياده كشفت ايضا ان
الدورها يبدا من بدايه تطوير اللعبه لدى
المطور بالنسبه للالعاب العالميه وذلك عبر
فحصها والتاكدي من موافقتها لتصنيف العمري
السعودي واعطائها تصنيفه وفقه ضوابط
التصنيف المحليه مضيفه بانه في حاله
الالعاب المستقله يتم تصنيفها اوتوماتيكيا
عن طريق النظام في الهيئه دون تدخل على ان
تتم رقابته لاحقا في حال وجود مشكله
تمثل المنتجعات البحريه ابرز الوجهات
السياحيه المفضله للشباب والعائلات من
مختلف الجنسيات في السعوديه بغرض
الاستمتاع وقضائي اجمل الاوقات والسبب
يعود الى الخدمات الترفيهيه الفاخره التي
توفرها تلك المنتجعات مثل الرياضات
البحريه
توفرها المنتجعات البحريه بشرق السعوديه
والتي يقصدها السياحه من مختلف الجنسيات
للاستمتاع باجوائها والاقامه فيها كما
تعرف السياحه في المنتجعات البحريه هي
موسميه فلذلك الاقبال جميل جدا عليها
وباذن الله نتامل اكثر الان مع موسم كاس
العالم ومع الاجازات القصيره الكثيره في
خلال السنه المنتجع يوفر في خدمات كثيره
خاصه في الاونه الاخيره وطور من الاماكن
الرئيسيه اللي في توفير الخدمات
تزيين الاماكن العامه فكان هذا سبب رئيسي
لوجودنا اليوم في هذا المكان
اللي زي كذا عندنا في الرياض
الاماكن هذه او همم التواجد في الاماكن
الرائعه والجميله هذه هي لمه العائله او
لمه ال- ال- ال- الاسره او الاسر عام تبني
حلم منتجعات البحريه خيارات ترفيهيه
للشباب والعائلات منها الرياضات البحريه
والمطاعم والمقاهي والعديد من وسائل
الترفيه المكان يجمع بين شباب وعوائل وفي
اللي مهتم في الالعاب البحريه المهتم في
الحدائق مهتم جلسات البحر والشوي والاشياء
هذه كلها موجوده يلا يا ربي لك الحمد
في الشواطئ نظيفه في ما شاء الله القوارب
المائيه في الاشياء هذه تخلي الانسان يدفع
فلوس بس مجرد واحد ثاني مره هون الجو كثير
حلو حبيت كثير
لاجواء الحلوه اللي عاملين اللعب للاولاد
المسابح المطاعم كل شيء هون حلو
في السعوديه ومستهدفا ناجحا للسياحه بفضل
منتجاته المثلى ابرزها سياحه المنتجعات
احد العوامل المحفزه لجذب المزيد من الفرص
الاستثماريه من المنطقه الشرقيه عن اللقب
العربيه
متى موسم الرياض مصنع للمواهب الشابه
السعوديه خاصه في مجالات العزف على
الموسيقى
فعاليات الموسم الفرق الفنيه السعوديه من
مختلف مناطق المملكه
[موسيقى]
في المطاعم والاماكن المفتوحه بمناطق
الموسم الحدث الترفيهي الاضخم في المنطقه
ال الشيخ على دعم اهلنا وتاحه مثلها
الاماكن اللي نقدم فيها مواهبنا انس مختار
واحد من ابرز العازفين على اله الناي
الموسيقيه جاء هو وفرقته من محافظه جده
غرب السعوديه لاقامه الحفلات الغنائيه
داخل المطاعم والمقاهي في منطقه البوليفار
والله ما شاء الله احنا في في المواسم
شباب سعوديين موسيقيين يعني دائما ما شاء
الله بنت الطالب هنا وهنا وزي ما انت شايف
ما شاء الله اكثر الاماكن والحمد لله فرصه
حلوه ان الشباب ما شاء الله يعني ايش
اشتغلوا مع بعض ونتقوى ومنها كمان يعني
انه ااه الموسيقين السعوديين كلهم حضور
يعني في المواسم
[تصفيق]
يمنحوا موسم الرياض فرصه ثمينه للشباب
السعوديين الذين يعتمدون على تاديه الغناء
والعزف كمصدر دخل اساسي لهم وتطويل
مواهبهم ومهاراتهم في ذات الوقت من الرياض
نواف عزيز العربيه
[موسيقى]
وسط ما يقرب من 200 جناح للدول المشاركه
في قمه المناخ يكسوها اللون الاخضر
والامال المعلقه على انقاذ البيئه وتطوير
انظمه الطاقه الصديقه كان الجناح
الاوكراني ايضا يكسو رماد الحرب
على البيئه
الجنوبيه حيث البحار والجبال والثلوج
امريكا ولكن يبقى الجناح الاوكراني فريدا
فالواقع وصوره وديكوراته عكست حجم الدمار
البيئيه الذي تعيشه بسبب الحرب
اشجار نقتلعت من جذورها وصور وارقام تجسد
حجم الخسائر التي طالت الارض التي كانت
تصنف بسله العالم من القمح
وحجمه الخسائر في الماشيه التي تنتج
اطنانا من الغذاء
القائمون على الجناح اكدوا ان الديكور نجح
في لفت الانظار وعكس الرساله الاوكرانيه
للمشاركين في القمه
الدمار الخسائر والاضرار البيئيه كبيره
وهذا ما حاولنا ايصاله من خلال هذا الجناح
ولان قمه المناخ تسعى لتوحيد الجهود
لمواجهه التحديات التي تواجه كوكب الارض
بعيدا عن السياسه
كل دوله على عرض رسالتها في جناحها
من قال نعود مباشره الى شرم الشيخ ونشاهد
هذه الصور للقاء الذي يجمع الرئيسين
الامريكي جوبايد الذي وصلت قبل قليل
المشاركه في انفعاليات قمه شرم الشيخ ب 27
ورئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه التي تستضيف هذه
القمه والتي تناقش الكثير من الملفات
المتعلقه
بالبيئه في قمه ايضا ينظر اليها الكثير
وخاصه المراقبين لمجال الطاقه والبيئه على
انها قمه مهمه وحساسه وتاتي في ضرب الدقيق
البعض يعني يصفها بقمه الفرصه الاخيره
لانقاذ البشريه كما يقول البعض طبعا همم
الانبعاث الحراري والدرجه التي وصلت اليها
حراره الارض
والتطورات ايضا المناخيه التي او التحديات
التي يشاهدتها او شهيدتها بعض دول العالم
خاصه في اوروبا كما ركبنا وتابعنا في
الاشهر الاخيره اذا وصول الرئيس الامريكي
جوبادل الى قمه شرم الشيخ للمشاركه في هذه
القمه من المنتظر
الرئيس الامريكي
على مهام هذه القمه
وخاصه يعني في ضوء المؤشرات والتحديات
التي يمر بها العالم مناقيا
كانت قمه شرم الشيخ قد ايه بدات في الايام
القليله الماضيه
باللقاءات وكذلك الكثير من الفعاليات
والخطابات والكثير من الجلسات ايضا التي
تمت على هامش هذه القمامه
اللي بتخص
القضايا القضايا المنطقه كان دائما التوجه
فيها توجه واحده
[موسيقى]
اول ارقام
في هذه المباراه بمدينه
انا اشوف
القضايا المختلفه
ورئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي في هذا
اللقاء ياتي على هامش الفعاليات المشاركه
الرئيس الامريكي في قمه شرم الشيخ كوب 27
[موسيقى]